he's Joe Girardi just turned 55 and he's
got a new job as uh the manager of the
Philadelphia Phillies Joe good to have
you back on how's life life is good Dan
how are you I'm good I'm curious of
stepping away from the game whether you
wanted to or not but just how that kind
of helps you in you know as you move
forward with the new job I think it
makes you realize a lot of things I
think number one it it makes you
appreciate the game more and helps you
understand don't ever take it for
granted and it teaches you how much you
really miss the game when you are away
from it I think it gives you a different
perspective for a couple years
a perspective maybe where you're not
under a microscope and everything that
you do and you can watch and enjoy the
game and learn from the game and learn
about people and it just in an
unprecedent it helps you understand all
that different things that are going on
in the game analytically better so and
just you become a fan again and you get
to watch the game from a fan's
perspective and I think it's important
we never forget that what is it about
the the catching position that helps in
you know making some pretty good
managers here because AJ Hinch Ned Yost
yourself Bruce Bochy you know this isn't
a coincidence you guys have won World
Series and you know the catcher seems to
be the go-to guy when we're looking at a
manager here I think there's a couple
different things I think you have
somewhat of an understanding of what
it's like to be a pitcher because you
work so closely but you also understand
what it's like to be a position player
that plays every day you know for me I
used to manage games in my mind all the
time
from a run prevention standpoint
thinking about okay this is what you
know I know we have in our bowl pen
tonight
this is what I need from our starter how
do I do it how do I get this guy through
this in that so I think you're you're
thinking of managing a game all the time
when you're a catcher and maybe it's
just training on the job the game last
night as a former catcher and you saw
that play it for his bass and what did
you see and what would you have called
right yeah you know to me I think he's
going to beat it it to me the problem is
not to play the problem is the way our
bass is designed I think we need to
change it because you're asked to run
you know from 45 feet on on the right
side the foul line and then you're
supposed to step on the bass with your
left foot it's just not humanly possible
really so why not add an extension on
the bass on the other side so you can
run through the bass on the other side
and we get rid of this silly judgment
called that these poor are briars have
to make on a split second they don't
have a chance to watch it slow motion
and replay to see if it's actually
interference or not so you know I hope
that we become weary activists and we
react to this in the proper way work
let's just change the bass can we just
change the bass so we don't have to deal
with this rule that is a radical radical
move so you would extend the bass across
into the into foul territory yes I mean
if we're supposed to run in voluntary
foul territory as base runners the final
45 feet can't we just run straight
through it and stay in foul territory
because here's the other thing there are
injuries that happen because of that
play you know Guri else lucky he didn't
hurt his wrist cliff Floyd it almost
cost him his career you know we've
eliminate breakup slides at second we've
eliminated guys getting run over at home
that play is as dangerous as possible
and I know from a manager I've talked
about moving a catcher you know on days
that he's not catching to play a little
bit of first base a talented catcher and
management is always afraid because
they're afraid they're gonna get hurt
because of that play the chances of that
play happening in the game aren't great
but we've seen it before wow I never
thought of that but it but it is it does
make a lot of sense I mean you know the
the rule itself and sometimes these
rules it's like the Tuck rule in with
Tom Brady you know they called it in
accordance to the rule I just I have a
problem with the rule I think last night
the throw is the problem they're not
Trey Turner and I do think that he would
have that ball either would have hit him
or he would have come in contact with
the glove of Uriel
even if he didn't run inside of you know
the first base line yeah it it's the law
you know it's the rule you know and
sometimes I I think the rule doesn't
always make sense you know I've never
thought the block rule has made sense
right I you know now you can't go from
third to first but you can inside move
at second I mean aren't you trying to
deceive the runner I mean what's the
difference from third to first or the
inside so I I think there's rules that
we really need to evaluate not only for
the good of the game but also to keep
players safe he's Joe Girardi the
Phillies manager joining us Dan Patrick
show tougher managing professional
baseball players or daughters Oh
daughters I think because you go home
every night and they're they're
professional baseball players we get to
leave in for about 12 hours a day I
remember when I saw you when we were at
a restaurant and I you were trying to
absorb everything I was telling you
about raising daughters and I could just
see it I was like all Jill you have no
clue okay yeah you're you're in for it
well they're 20 and 13 now and I have a
son in between who's 17 so I'm knee-deep
in it
awesome and they're daddy's girls and I
love it but yeah I mean sometimes it's
tricky what is the biggest change that
has to happen with the Phillies we need
to stay healthy as an organization
number one we need to keep our bullpen
healthy we need to keep our leadoff
hitter healthy and just keep players on
the field that's first and foremost and
I think if we do that we give ourselves
a really good shot in our division and
players has to play to their potential
because I think there's a lot of talent
here and I really believe there'll be
some additions that come along just like
any other team during the offseason and
I'm excited to see you know who those
players might be but health is really
important of all the pitchers that you
could put on the mound for a game seven
in today's game aside from yours so you
don't get
with that with the Phillies but who
would you want on the mound well I think
if you look at today's day and age I
think Eric Cole has been the most
dominant pitcher Stephen Strasburg has
been special too so I think you could
look at those two guys and what they've
done and I mean you know in the day of
all this bullpen that we do and I
understand why organizations do it and
I've had to do it pass just because it's
the makeup of your team think about how
important starting pitching has been to
this series and now they have you know
been a big part of the success for these
two teams so you could handpick a number
of those guys that are in this series
and put them out there
you caught the white Goodin's no-hitter
I think and David cones perfect game is
that right correct do you direct now
what do you get from Dwight Gooden and
David Cone after that achievement well
the first thing is the organization
gives you a home plate which is really
neat the pitchers get the rubber and the
the catcher gets the home plate and you
do different things with it and I have
mine in a big case and it's and I never
realized how heavy they were until I got
my first one you know we're used to that
little thing that we just lay down in
the backyard light it is yeah it's
really heavy so it's a great memorabilia
and then watches and rings you know each
guy bought things for everyone that was
involved and it was really special I'll
leave you with this Soto and Bregman
taken their bats to first base I guess
we're in the category because of our age
of being old school where do you stand
on this with the baseball and these
these hitters having some fun or
celebrating well I think Bregman won his
went further in Soto's it ended up I
think beyond first base but you know I
think the manager spoke about it you
know they didn't necessarily like it and
I think when you do that you open
yourself up to criticism and you'll
yourself you know there's that old
saying you know never wake up a sleeping
dog in a sense so I think sometimes you
do that
I love the celebrations in the dugout
obviously the driving the car is my
favorite one but I also love all the
looks
like Bregman gives when he hits a
homerun and what they do so that I'm all
okay to me it's as long as you're not
showing anyone up that's all like if
you're showing someone up I have a
problem you're having fun and and you're
just doing it out of you know being
spontaneous I'm okay with it well you
got Bryce Harper and it just feels like
yeah he rubs people the wrong way
sometimes just by being Bryce Harper Jo
well I think he's one of those guys no
matter what he does it's never going to
be good and I felt that way about a-rod
I always felt like he rod could hit 50
homers and driving 150 ribbies and
because of who he was
you're never going to get up and go to
the restroom during one of his at-bats
and you're always going to find
something to criticize or like oh he
should have done that or he should have
given us a little bit more so I think
Bryce Harper falls into that category
and I think the talent level he has is a
real blessing but that part of it
sometimes is the curse that comes with
the real blessing is the expectations
are so high
sometimes you can't meet them before I
let you go we have a guy who works with
us
McLovin and a Philly guy big Philly fan
hey he doesn't have he doesn't think
that managers really do much no it was
rated that's not what I said I think
that's a direct quote McLovin I said
some organizations you said who's more
valuable the equipment manager or the
manager McLovin Joe dances mad at me
because I already Requested November
first off of next year to go to Philly
and when we get there I will host all
right hey Joe it's great to talk to you
and good luck we appreciate it so Dan
how old are your daughters now my
daughters are 21 24 and 26 now are you
out of the woods yet in a sense or you
still I got you know what still night
for me
one still in college one in law school
but I got three weddings and then my
funeral so I got I got I got to pay for
those I will say and I said it to you
that night with your wife just become a
great listener that's
all that that's the best advice I can
tell any dad with daughters you're a
catcher with a pitcher and you got to
listen to them because you know your
pitchers are drama queen so you just
listen to what they have to say you
don't have to give advice as much as you
just listen that's all that that is
great advice and I appreciate and the
checks in the mail
thank you Joe that's a Joe Girardi for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]